[موسيقى]
نظره الدول ايضا المحيطه والقوه الاقليميه
ايضا في هذه المنطقه الى ايضا هذا الاتساع
الضخم في الدوله السعوديه وايضا دخول هذه
الانحاء المختلفه في الجزيره العربيه تحت
حكم واحد لاول مره في التاريخ يعني ربما
بعد
ايام عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه ولهذا لم
تحكم الجزيره العربيه بحكم واحد الا لهذه
الاسره ولهذا استشعروا هذه الدول ايضا
باخطار ستحدق عليهم
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا كانت ايضا الدوله لا تغيب عنها
الشمس لكنها استشعرت ايضا الخطر السعودي
من امتداد السعوديين الى المنافذ البحريه
وكانت البريطانيا لا تغيب عنها الشمس لان
دوله تجاريه في المقام الاول ولهذا حتى مع
اعداء الدوله السعوديه كانت في سقوط
الدوله السعوديه ايضا حاولوا ايضا عقد
الاتفاقيه معهم لايضا لابعاد الجذور
السعوديه عن البلاد المنطقه السواحل لان
كانوا يتحكمون ايضا في السعوديين
فاستشعروا بريطانيا ايضا بذلك الامر ايضا
حتى الفرنسيين في بعض الرسائل التي قام
بها ايضا نابليون في فتره من فتراته ارسال
ايضا
[موسيقى]